the idea behind startup shiba XYZ isn't
new but it's the first time it's being
put into practice here in Bangladesh she
wakes oh is it is a service marketplace
while people people can buy services for
the daily needs we are kind of Amazon
for services so whatever services you
need to just go to our site or app and
search it and you will get it the
service platform hooks up plumbers
carpenters or beauticians in Dhaka with
customers but that's not all so we teach
them you know the basic thing about the
Shiva the values then the basic behavior
what they need to maintain whom they
serve mainly the spiraling towards the
customer and you know to solve it with
you know professionally and third we
show them how to use the service using
the app okay it's a basic thing from an
Agora guard you we bring basic education
to them right we are helping them to
grow their business so we want them to
be successful entrepreneur according to
art non mta's Halim trades people's work
in bangladesh hasn't changed in decades
most people are self-employed and just
managed to make ends meet up to now
they've had little opportunity to
improve the situation we believe that a
simple education on their skill
and basic professionalism can change the
whole game he takes us to a small car
workshop to show what these changes
might look like so he owned these garage
I know him for two years plus when we
started the business I found him - you
know fixing one car a day maxximum and
by himself and now he has eight
resources so he runs a small business
Bangladesh is one of the poorest
countries in the world and it has a
rapidly growing population
[Music]
for many people here it's a daily
struggle for survival
[Music]
[Music]
the difficult conditions mean everyone
has to pitch in even the children in
Bangladesh there are some 3.5 million
child laborers Habib has been working in
the shoe factory since he was 10 years
old I sleep back there my family faces
huge hardship I work to ease the
pressure on them when I get my salary
here I send money to my mother in her
village school for many children isn't
an option but Habib is one of the lucky
ones
his lessons have been organised by a
Child Protection Agency and have an
uphill fight to help the children
slowly refuse to us God from my factory
but we communicate to the parents and
the factory owner
only 40 hours your children can get
opportunity education after they can go
to the art shop so they actually they
study the Bangladesh government seems to
be focused on investment to encourage
change and give a much-needed boost to a
lagging economy for example investments
in startups as a country we have started
later but we want to actually develop
the ecosystem of the business
entrepreneur the company like Shabaab
this kind of new thinking you see the
uber type of thinking or like Airbnb
type of thinking it is already accepted
by the whole world now we need our local
homegrown solutions just to introduce it
the team in the high-level MTA's Halim
gave up a well-paid job to start the
company he says it'll take a few years
yet before shiba XYZ turns a profit he
has no doubts about his decision he says
his work on the platform is already
bearing fruit so we need more
entrepreneurs to create job for others
yes that's right so our our target is to
create 10,000 entrepreneurs by next 18
months that's the objective you know go
so 10,000 entrepreneur will create job
employment from 100k one you know
hundred key resources wow that's that's
a big step so that's the biggest thing
the online platform is set to expand
into a number of other Asian countries
after all it's not just in Bangladesh
that workers need new opportunities
[Music]